ينضم الينا من منطقه المواصي جنوب قطاع
غزه مراسل الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي مؤمن
نتابع معك الاوضاع الانسانيه في ظل
الاحوال الجويه السيئه فضلا عن التطورات
[موسيقى]
الميدانيه نعم فدا هي اوضاع انسانيه صعبه
مع مزيد من دفعات النازحين الى منطقه رفح
نتواجد هنا في منطقه المواصي غرب مدينه
خانيونس ونشاهد اعمده الدخان تصاعد من
المنطقه الغربيه القريبه من منطقه المواصي
قبل قليل طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه شنت
سلسله من الغارات على هذه المنطقه وادى
الى ارتفاع ارتقاء عدد من الشهداء وصل الى
النقطه الطبيه كما نشاهد على هذه على هذه
نشاهد عربه تقل جثامين عدد من الشهداء قبل
ذلك وصل جثماني شهيدين والان ثالث او رابع
عبر هذه العربه الى نقطه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي بذلك
يرتفع عدد الشهداء نتيجه الغاره القريبه
من هذه المنطقه الى اربعه من الشهداء الى
جانب عدد من الاصابات وصلوا كما تشاهدون
عبر وسائل نقل بدائيه وايضا بالسيارات الى
هذه النقطه التي استحدثها واسسها الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني بعد الحصار المشدد لليوم
السادس على التوالي الذي تفرضه قوات
الاحتلال داخل مدينه خانيونس على مستشفى
الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال وايضا على
مجمع ناصر الطبي ايضا القصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي يتواصل على مختلف المناطق في
مدينه خان يونس اعمده الدخان تتصاعد في
اكثر من منطقه سواء في المنطقه الغربيه او
في وسط مدينه خان يونس او في الحي
النمساوي جنوب مدينه خان يونس وايضا منطقه
المشروع شمال مدينه خان يونس حيث تدور في
هذه المحاور المشتعله اشتباكات عنيفه
ضاريه بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المقاومه تحاول منع
اي توغل وتقدم اسرائيلي في بعض المحاور
داخل المدينه بعد الحصار المشدد الذي
فرضته قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على تطويق
المدينه من جميع اتجاهاتها من الناحيه
الغربيه والشماليه وايضا الشرقيه سابقا
بالاضافه الى المنطقه الجنوبيه حيث يقع
الحي النمساوي ومحيط المستشفى الميداني
الاردني يشهد هو الاخر اشتباكات مسلحه بين
المقاومه وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا
استشهد نازح فلسطيني داخل مقر مستشفى
الامل التابع لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني نتيجه القصف المدفعي الكثيف
الذي تتعرض له هذه المنطقه وهناك مناشدات
للمجتمع الدولي بضروره الضغط على سلطات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لرفع الحصار المفروض
على هذا المكان الذي يؤوي اكثر من 7000
نازح الى جانب المئات من الجرحى والمرضى و
الكوادر الطبيه ويعرض حياتهم لخطر شديد مع
استمرار الحصار لليوم السادس على التوالي
بالاضافه الى مجمع الناصر الطبي الذي يعيش
اوضاعا انسانيه غايه في الصعوبه مع النقص
الحاد في المستلزمات الطبيه والادويه
وايضا الكوادر الطبيه مع استمرار وصول
المئات من الجرحى بالاضافه الى الاف
النازحين الذين احتموا داخل اسوار مجمع
ناصر الطبي هربا من شده القصف والغارات
الاسرائيليه وصلتنا مناشدات طيله هذا
اليوم من قبل النازحين يقولون ان هناك في
مربع محيط مجمع ناصر الطبي اكثر من 10000
نازح يعانون من نقص حاد في توفير المواد
التموينيه والغذائيه بالاضافه الى المياه
الصالحه للشرب وايضا الغارات الاسرائيليه
تتواصل في محيطهم وصل الى مجمع ناصر الطبي
قبل قليل ثلاث اصابات نتيجه استهداف
اسرائيلي استهدف مدرسه الخلديه وهي مدرسه
تابعه للاونروا تووي الاف النازحين حين
الوضع في داخل المدينه وضع غايه في
الصعوبه والتعقيد مع استمرار الغارات
والقصف المدفعي الاسرائيلي وعلى مدار
الساعه تصل الى هذه النقطه الطبيه المزيد
من الاصابات وجثامين الشهداء عبر وسائل
نقل بدائيه وعبر سيارات ومن هنا يتم نقلهم
عبر الاسعافات الى المستشفيات المتواجده
داخل مدينه رفح سواء الى مستشفى ابو يوسف
النجار وهو المستشفى الحكومي الوحيد الذي
يعمل داخل مدينه رفح الى جانب المستشفى
الكويتي الاوضاع صعبه للغايه هنا وا نسمع
بين الفينه والاخرى دوي انفجارات وغارات
جويه بالاضافه الى تحليق مكثف للطائرات
الحربيه وايضا طائرات الاستطلاع على
ارتفاعات منخفضه في المنطقه الغربيه
لمدينه خانيونس والتي تشهد طيله الايام
السابقه اشتباكات ضاريه بين المقاومه
وقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تتوغل في
في تخوم المنطقه التي نقف بها الدبابات
جيش الاحتلال تبعد ما يقرب 500 متر عن
المنطقه التي نقف بها والان نسمع دوي
انفجار ناجم عن قصف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه للمنطقه الغربيه من مدينه خان
يونس شكرا لك مؤمن الشرافي مراس جزيره كنت
معنا من منطقه المواصي جنوب قطاع غزه